can you um
like wikipedia style or maybe like in in
a musical form like i'm only a bill
describe to me uh i i still sing that to
my head sometimes
i'm just a bill
uh i don't know what the rest of the
song is but let's let's uh
let's leave that to people's imagination
uh how
how does this whole thing work how does
the u.s political system work
the three branches is how do you think
about
the system we have now if you were to
try to describe
if aliens showed up and asked you
like they didn't have time so this is an
elevator
thing should we destroy you and be
as you plead to avoid destruction
how how would you uh describe how this
thing works i would say
we come together and we pick the people
who make our laws
then we pick the guy who executes those
laws
and they together pick the people who
determine
whether they or the president is
breaking the law
at the most basic level that's how i
would describe it so
the so that's the people who make the
laws are congress
the executive is is charged with
executing the laws as passed by congress
assistant
branches of government and the supreme
court is picked by the president
confirmed by the senate
which then decides whether you or
other people are breaking the law in
terms of interpretation
of that law that's basically it oh and
they
they decide whether those laws are
in they fall within the
they fall within the restrictions
and the want of the founders as
expressed
by the constitution of the united states
which is a set of principles that we
came together
in 1787. i want to make sure i get this
right
um 1787 and decided that we were going
to live
the rest of our lives barring a
revolution and more
and we've made it 200 and something
years in order on under that system
so there's a balance of power there's
because it's multiple branches
there's a tension and a balance to it as
designed by those original documents uh
what which is the most dysfunctional the
branches which is your favorite
like uh in terms of talking about
systems and like
what's the greatest of concern and what
is the greatest
source of benefit in your view the
presidency obvious well the presidency
is my favorite to study obviously
because
it is the one where there's most
subjective variable change
in terms of the personality involved
because of so much power imbued within
the executive
the senate is actually pretty much the
same
one of the things i love about reading
about the senate and histories of the
senate
is you're like oh yeah there were always
like [ __ ] in the senate who were
doing their
thing and and you know filibustering
constantly
based upon this or that and then the
pers the personalities involved with the
senate
haven't mattered as much since like
pre-civil war right like pre-civil war
you had like henry clay and then
daniel webster and john c calhoun who
even in their own way they represented
like larger constituencies and they
crafted these like compromises
up until the outbreak of the civil war
et cetera but like post since
then you don't think about like the
titans within the senate
most of that is because a lot of the
stuff that they had power over has
transferred over
to the executive so i'm most interested
in really in like
power like where it lies it's actually
pretty you know throughout american
history
much more used to lie with congress now
it's obviously just so imbued within the
executive
that understanding executive power is i
think the thing i'm probably most
interested in here
you